bonjour je m'appelle c'est d'abord pour
la mini j'ai 14 ans je fais deux radios
et une fille persévérant de bonne
volonté et qui arrive toujours à ses
fins elle m'a appris beaucoup de choses
sur moi-même
en grandissant son antique a ralenti pas
sa scolarité elle a grandi sans que moi
même j'étais dr oui tu es le handicap
n'a pas le droit de faire ça non contre
elle pourrait étouffer et c'est en
faisant des bêtises qu'elle a appris
plein de choses c'est les coupes de
d'être à genoux c'est quand j'arrive
dernière d'un accès à une récompense
beaucoup d'accords verticaux mon plaisir
je dis je on va voir qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire on l'a même pas regardé le
handicap pour la chine met dans le
groupe et voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire question même si c'est pas la même
distance même si c'est pas pareil mais
on a six ou huit syndicats considèrent
qu'il faut continuer même si on arrive
des nues
elle donne aussi cette leçon de vie
comme quoi qui veut peux tu regardes
parmi les marmailles le plus grand super
c'est elle c'est tout le temps comme ça
c'est elle qui nous apporte le souverain
c'est pas nous merci à tous de
m'encourager jusqu'au bout d'acteur